par mois au milieu des moutons poubelles
pour savina le simple fait d'ouvrir le
réfrigérateur peut devenir angoissant
j'ai l'impression que je vais te manger
des aliments que ça peut être n'importe
quoi la femme de 28 ans souffrent du
trouble de l'alimentation sélective
irritante
elle évite donc des aliments de peur
qu'ils soient contaminés des fruits et
légumes avec la pelure et fruits de mer
les aliments non cuit entre autres
j'avais acheté un prêt la veille fait je
le fasse
j'ai ouvert où ils sont le poulet ok
mais ça sont des fois mes douleurs
physiques ou non il ne doit pas être bon
quatre personnes amel c'était qu'il ya
une odeur est à les contenir des animaux
frigo qui verra tout ça pouvait être un
jeune habitant pas après résultats
dénutrition points inférieurs à ce qui
est recommandé
les conséquence apparente finalement à
l'anorexie sauf que le désir n'est pas
de perdre du poids des impacts le
fonctionnement cérébral et tous les
fonctions physiologiques et c'est
dégringole alors la personne devient de
plus en plus c'est que angoisses et les
troubles de l'alimentation sélective est
évidente est diagnostiqué depuis
quelques années seulement
il toucherait 3 % des jeunes les causes
sont multiples alors c'est un peu les
préoccupations bio pris à une extrême
les pressions culturelles de manger
sainement de garder une trace de ces
d'éviter les ingrédients non naturelles
etc
ça c'est l'allumette qui va déclencher
la bombe d'un trouble de l'alimentation
mais il ya de nombreux autres facteurs
il c'est clair que ce sont des choses
qui ont une hérédité assez important et
on voit ça souvent dans d'autres aspects
de leur fonctionnement
ils sont trop travaillante au travail
étudie cros savina elle vient de
terminer un programme intensif à
l'institut universitaire en santé
mentale douglas
elle est toujours suivie mais une fois
semaine sur une presque normale pendant
ma tête
maintenant elle n'y aucun coup et les
experts rappellent que si la nourriture
ou le poids prend trop de place dans
votre vie des ressources existent et que
oui il est possible de guérir d'un
trouble alimentaire ici marie laurence
de l'aîné radio canada montréal